Okay.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Muhammadu.
[Silence]
One of the most knowledgeable companions
of the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam
and hence one of the most knowledgeable
men to ever walk the earth
with regards to the religion and will of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
reported in his j
that this companion Abdah
who said
[Silence]
He said, "Whoever wishes to
read
what the prophet Muhammad Muhammad
sallall.aii wasallam would have written
in his will.
Had he written a will and a final will
and testament
before his passing
what would he have writtend?
He says
he would have written or he should read
the statement of Allah.
verses number 151,
152,
153 of chapter number six, surah.
So had he left a will, his will would
have in so many words
merely
repeated
what Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala said in
these three verses.
Let us read these verses. These are
referred to as the both most basic and
fundamental laws of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
the most fundamental
prohibitions of Allah.
All other laws revolve around these core
laws that Allah mentions in these three
verses.
He begins by saying
speaking to the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam say to them, "Come, rise
up and let me recite to you and
implement and set an example for you as
to what your Lord has prohibited upon
you."
The first of these prohibitions,
the most grave of these prohibitions,
do not associate
anyone or anything
in your worship of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. Do not associate unto Allah
anyone or anything
in your worship of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
Most times a person when they hear
the issue of worshiping Allah alone
without any partners,
they will
associate this only with the worship
of idols. Meaning what is
what what does it look like? What is the
appearance of a person who has fallen
into shik?
It is
that a person will worship idols. If a
person is not worshiping idols, they are
safe from a shik. And this could not be
more incorrect.
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam said to
Abu Bakr,
He said
that shik and its types
and
its varants
are more silent
in my ummah than the footsteps of an ant
on granite rock.
Meaning that if a person is not looking
for it, if a person doesn't go out of
his way to learn what it is in order to
avoid it, they will almost assuredly
fall into it.
And that is why this is so important and
it's
ironically
so very overlooked
in
thank you so very overlooked
amongst many Muslims
in our time
and that is that a person will have the
false impression or the mis
misunderstanding
that, you know, I'm Muslim. I was born a
Muslim. I grew up around Muslims.
So, of course, I know,
you know, automatically the majority of
what Islam tells me.
And this statement may have been correct
if a person were living in Medina in the
time of the companions
where the only thing that they are
seeing practiced is the sunnah of the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam.
However,
this argument or this rationalization
is no different than a person saying I'm
human. I was born human. I've always
been human.
I grew up around human beings. And so
I am also a qualified doctor, right? I'm
I'm human. I know what is good for the
body and what is bad for the body. I
know what is a cure for the body and
what is not. This would
be absurd. we would not accept this kind
of rationalization.
Likewise
is the issue with regards to
the notion of a shik.
There are many many dozens of types of
shik that the prophet sallall.aii Wasam
taught the companions
and instructed them on how to avoid.
And here the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam is telling Abu Bakr Sudik of
all people, the most knowledgeable
and virtuous man
of all mankind after the prophets and
messengers of Allah.
He is telling him
that the types of shik in my
are so silent, so discreet,
so
unassuming
that they are comparable. the types of
shik to the footsteps
of an ant on granite. This is something
that if you do not go out of your way to
learn and look for,
you will not be able to just rationalize
yourself to the finish line. And so
for this reason,
a person to studyahill
and its pillars and obligations
and implications
and
what it entails from what it does
not. This is absolutely critical in a
Muslim's journey to Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala gives the
first prohibition.
He says
that you not associate anyone or
anything
that you not associate another unto
Allah in your worship of Allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
He says,
"And he further commands you to perfect
your interactions
and your treatment of the parents,
the parents, whoever they are.
This
is a position that is respected
even if the person in that position is
not a respectable person.
So when it comes to a parent
for instance, a mother, a father, we
live in a time and in a place that
rationalizes
the good and fair treatment of a parent.
And the idea is my parent has to earn my
respect.
My parent, my father, my mother has to
earn my
friendship and good treatment of them.
And that is incorrect
because Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
commanded
that the position of a parent be
respected
and be honored
and be
and be exalted
irrespective of who is in that position.
Even if a person's father or mother is
not Muslim,
even if a person's father or mother
were to be himself,
a person respects the position,
not necessarily always the person in the
position.
Meaning that a person's obedience of his
parent is innate.
It is innate.
It is immediate.
It is unconditional.
The only
thing that a person is not to do in the
path of respecting and honoring his
father or mother is to disobey Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala didn't just
command that a person obey his parent.
didn't just command that a person honor
his parent but that a person be an
adequate
companion of his parent companionship
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala commands
that we are to
not just obey our parents and honor our
parents and exalt ult our parents, but
we are to
perfect our companionship with our
parents.
And so a person can never honor his
parent too much
as long as the person does not disobey
Allah
in honoring his parent.
And so the person does not ever obey the
creation of Allah
in the disobedience of the creator Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala here
says
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
that we are not just to
we are not just to treat our parents
will and be companions to them and be
obedient to them. But we are to strive
for perfection
of every interaction with our parent.
And this is something that the parent
innately is given irrespective of who
the parent is.
This is not something that the parent
necessarily has to earn.
Now, notice what we're learning here.
Notice what we're saying here. A person
may say, "Well, my father or his father
or his mother is a terrible person, a
person that mistreated him, a person
that wasn't around, a person that they
only met after they were 20 years old
and a grown adult, a person who
abandoned them, etc., etc. the many
reasons people have.
However, as we mentioned, this is not
something that is necessarily earned by
the parent.
The parent does not have to earn the
obedience of his child.
The mere fact that the child came into
existence
by way of the actions of his parent.
This makes the child innately indebted
to his parent who no matter who the
parent is.
And if we were to earn kindness from
each other, this would be a very
terrible world we live in
because many people do not deserve
kindness.
Many people have not earned kindness.
Many people do not earn their rights.
However, these are things which are
innate
and it's very important for us to focus
on this issue here and that is
because we live in a time and in a place
not just in America but this is a
worldwide thing because of
how society is structured today and how
they communicate and what ideas are
propagated most prominently.
It is very important for us to
understand
what it is to honor one's parent and be
dutiful to one's parent
because we live in a time where
everything seems to be rationalized.
You rationalize everything that you do.
I will only do this if it if it seems
rational to me. Right? And so
I have to rationalize
obedience to my parent or honor of my
parent. I have to rationalize.
And then we see on television, in
movies, in popular culture, the child
is now in the position of the parent.
And the parent now is graveling
for the approval of his 2, three, four,
fiveyear-old child.
And that the child will
ignore the parent when the child gets
older for years. And the parent has to
strive
to earn the child's
affection.
And this is exactly the opposite of how
things should be.
Now
does this mean that it is not difficult
for a person to honor his parent who is
maybe had abandoned him, maybe was
abusive, which anyways the word abusive
is used so much now that it doesn't even
have a meaning anymore.
Kind of the word trauma. Everybody
has trauma.
Why is this person a terrible person?
Well, because they have childhood
trauma. Tell me somebody please amongst
us here raise your hand if you did not
have any trauma growing up or trauma in
this world. That person doesn't exist.
That's part of life.
Every one of us, if trauma didn't come
to you by way of your parents, it came
to you by way of someone else. This is
the nature of this world is it is a hard
and difficult place.
However, these are not excuses
for a person to abandon his parent. The
child's duty is to seek out the parent
and obey the parent even if the parent
does not reciprocate. As a matter of
fact, especially if the parent does not
reciprocate
because we do not treat people
how Allah commands us
because of the results of that thing.
We may obey Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
and do what we are told by Allah
and fulfill the rights of others and it
have no effect on bettering that person.
As a matter of fact, a person may be
kind to another person and that only
inflames and emboldens the other person
in their terrible behavior.
That is not our concern.
Our concern is not the fruit. When the
fruit comes, when the when the fruit
sprouts and ripens, we pick it. No
problem. But we have been commanded to
plant the tree.
And the fruits are to Allah's
discretion.
And Allah has mentioned to us that one
of the tests that we will endure as
believers on our journey to Allah
is that he will test us with
aat.
He will test us with a lack of fruits.
What does that mean? and a lack of
fruits. Meaning that our labor will be
very intensive
and it will seem we are never able
to have even a moment to wipe the sweat
from our brow and no fruits.
That's part of the test. Are we
worshiping the fruits or are we
worshiping Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala?
This is the difference between the
righteousness of the believer and the
righteousness of the disbeliever.
The disbeliever does what works for him
in the immediate
because what he is looking for is
success in the immediate.
But the believer
the believer worships Allah. He is
looking for the pleasure of Allah
irrespective of the results in the
material world.
And so a man came to the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam and he said to him
and this narration is in Muslim he
saidool
[Silence]
He said, "Oh messenger of Allah, I have
family ties. Kin, we don't know who the
kin are. Could be a parent, could be a
cousin,
someone of his family.
that I am good to them and they
reciprocate my goodness with evil
and I am gentle with them and they are
harsh with me
and I reach out to them and they
couldn't care less they did not
reciprocate that they never reach out to
me
the prophet sallallah alaihi wasallam
said
He said, "If
you are as you say, they're bad to you,
but you're good to them. They cut off
ties with you, but you keep ties and
insist on keeping ties with them.
You are pardoning and forgiving and
overlooking to them, and they are petty
with you. If you are, as you say,
then it is as if you are feeding them
baking hot desert sand.
He said, "And Allah will always be on
your side against them as long as you
continue as you say.
[Arabic recitation]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
mentions in the opening verses of Ali
a chapter that is so illustrious and so
virtuous
and of such merit
that the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam mentioned that it will come on
the day of judgment and intercede on
behalf of the one who used to live by it
recite it in the life of this world.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says in this
chapter
that Allah himself
hereby testifies
that none is rightfully worshiped but he
he testifies
and his angels testify
and the scholars from amongst his
creation those of knowledge testify.
None is rightfully worshiped by he
subhanahu wa ta'ala. This is what he
tells us in this verse, the mighty and
the all- wise.
We notice in this verse that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
calls
witness to the most
important fact and the most self-evident
truth
in our existence.
The most important thing that the human
being will ever know
and the most
important thing that the human being
will ever live for. The only true reason
to die for
as Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala here
mentions is the testimony to the oneness
of Allah.
This is the greatest truth.
It is inherent.
It is innate.
It is
true whether or not his creation
admits it.
The prophet sallall.aii
Wasam mentioned
that
said to one of his son said to his son.
He said,
he taught his son that if
were in one side of a scale
and the seven heavens and the seven
earths and all of creation were in the
other side of that scale,
would outweigh all of them. Why?
Because the creation
is of no use to Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala without the embodiment ofahill.
We are in desperate need ofahillahillah
and this truth is not in need of us to
be true. If all of humanity
adhered to
it would not make it any more true.
And if all of humanity were to
collaborate
in the rejection ofahill,
it would not make it any less true.
This is the greatest truth that Allah
has revealed to his creation about
himself,
about themselves.
And on such an important topic,
the most
important and grave of truths,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala cites the
testimony of his angels to this truth
and the testimony of the scholars
of humankind and genkind
the testimony of the people of
knowledge.
And he subhanahu wa ta'ala
calls and cites their testimony
alongside the testimony of the angels
and his testimony. Subhanahu wa tala.
This is the greatest honor
that has ever been mentioned with
regards to knowledge, scholarship and
its people.
This is the greatest honor
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala cites the
testimony
of the scholars
and cites it alongside his testimony and
that of his angels.
Who are the scholars? Who are the people
of knowledge?
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us
elsewhere in the Quran
that it is only
it is only
those
individuals of knowledge those scholars
from amongst Allah's slaves and servants
that truly fear Allah and exalt Exalt
him as he is due.
Notice the wording here only.
And so this here
can be referred to as a kind of circular
argument in a way. How is that?
Who are those who truly fear Allah? The
people of knowledge. Who are the people
of knowledge? those who truly fear Allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala.
But it's not just fear. It's
and in the Arabic language is fear that
is only had by way of knowledge.
A person of ignorance can never be a
person of
they might be a person of
just brute fear but the word in the
Arabic language is the sole domain of
those who know
that fear which is only had by way of
knowledge.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is contrary
to all of his creation in this regard
and that is that all of the creation no
matter how scary it is the more you get
to know it the less frightening it is
the less scary it is the more
comfortable you become with that thing
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala exactly ly the
opposite.
The less you know Allah, the less you
will fear him. And the more a person
gets to know Allah, the more that person
will come to fear Allah.
And so knowledge, scholarship,
what is knowledge?
Sometimes it almost seems we have
lost sight of what knowledge is.
We have confused knowledge
with
those who speak or those who have
followers or those who are influencers.
Is knowledge something
that is only
recognized by the number of followers
that it has?
Or is knowledge something
which the followers are weighed by?
This is a problem that we face today
and our thought the way that we see
things. We make a big deal about
something that everyone is making a big
deal about and we tend to ignore what
everyone is ignoring.
This is not how knowledge is. Knowledge
doesn't work that way. Knowledge is not
gauged by its followers.
Rather, its followers are gauged by that
knowledge.
Knowledge
is what Allah Subhanahu Wa Ta'ala
has left
by way of the prophets and the
messengers.
This is their inheritance.
Our prophet Muhammad sallall.aii Wasam
said
that
he said
that the prophets and messengers do not
leave behind to their heirs a single
gold or silver coin.
Rather, what they leave behind
and their inheritance is knowledge.
And whoever has or is given of that
knowledge has been given an incredible
gift, an inheritance.
And so the heirs of the prophet Muhammad
sallall.aii wasallam are the people of
knowledge.
And no people
will ever be successful
without knowledge.
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam
gave us a gauge
to see where we are with respect to the
path of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Are we on the path of Allah
or are we on our way to misguidance?
How can we know as a nation, as a
people, as a community, as an
individual?
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam gave us
that gauge. He said in the narration of
Bkari, a Muslim,
that if Allah subhanahua
wishes good for any person, whomever
Allah wishes good for, he will grant him
understanding and knowledge of the
religion. the religion of Islam,
not just facts, not just information
about Islam, but understanding.
And there is a difference between
intelligence and knowledge.
information and understanding.
And there is a difference between
knowledge and wisdom.
Those things
are not the same.
And if a person were to have a lot of
information, this doesn't necessarily
make that person a person of knowledge.
And if a person
were to have a lot of knowledge, it
doesn't necessarily make them a person
of wisdom.
This is something that is only had by
way of following the path of the
scholarship of Islam.
From the time of our prophet Muhammad
sallall.aii wasallam, he tells us
whomever Allah desires good for,
he will grant him understanding of the
religion.
Notice the wording. Whomever
he decides or desires good for, whomever
he wills to give good, he prefaces that
good with knowledge.
This goes for individuals
and groups. This goes for communities
and nations.
This goes for entire civilizations.
that if it is a civilization, a people,
a community, a country
that respects and follows its
scholarship, I'm not talking about
physicists, I'm not speaking about
mathematicians,
I'm not speaking about medical
professionals, this is knowledge. But in
the Quran and Sunnah, in the language of
the Quran and Sunnah, when the word
knowledge is used, it is a reference to
knowledge
that the prophet Muhammad sallall.aii
wasallam brought to us from Allah.
that if Allah desires good for any
individual or people,
he will grant them knowledge and
understanding of this religion.
The opposite is also true that if Allah
does not desire good for a person or
people, he will not grant them
understanding
of their religion
because knowledge is the only way to the
pleasure of Allah.
And this leaves us with a great
misunderstanding
that many of us suffer from today. Yet
even if we are unable to put it into
words
this un this misunderstanding that I'm
really really smart and if a person is
super smart they can think their way to
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
they will rationalize themselves to the
path of Allah
or this idea
that a person if they have really good
intentions s they don't necessarily need
knowledge.
If they have a general outline of good
and bad and their intentions are really
really pure, they can accidentally
stumble their way into the graces of
Allah.
This could not be further from the
truth.
Knowledge is a map.
A person, no matter how determined they
are and no matter how pure their
intentions
and no matter how strong their desire
to go to a particular place, they will
never accidentally find themselves there
if they just stumble around.
This is something that only comes by way
of knowledge. It's a road map. A person
in order to arrive at a destination must
know how to get there. Otherwise, they
will never get there. It won't happen.
This is something that many of us
misunderstand.
The idea that if my intentions are
really good, I don't have to have a map.
I can just jump in the car, gas it up,
and just go really fast in a particular
direction, and I'll eventually get there
accidentally.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is greater
than that. And he is worth much more
than that and he is far more worthy than
that. Subhanahu Waaala.
Knowledge is the lifeline of this ummah.
And it is only by way of its scholars
that this ummah will remain firmly
planted on the path of Allah.
And any people that are to drift and
stray from that path that stray that
straying from the path of Allah begins
with the absence of the people of
knowledge.
Abdah
narrated as was collected by
and others
that the prophet sallall.aii Wasam
said
[Silence]
The prophet Sam,
our messenger said to us, he said
samallam
that Allah does not take back knowledge,
the knowledge of the Quran, knowledge of
the sunnah. He does not take it from a
people by extracting it from the hearts
of men.
Rather, he takes back knowledge by way
of the death of scholars.
And this process will continue. The
death of scholars will continue in a
people until there are no scholars left.
And the people will then naturally
take ignorant leaders for themselves.
And these ignorant leaders are not just
ignorant but they are ignorant of the
fact that they are ignorant which is the
most which is the most frightening type
of ignorance compounded ignorance that a
person doesn't know and thinks he knows
and they will then hence be asked and
they will answer without knowledge and
they will then at that point go astray
and take others astray with them.
And for this reason, Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
mentioned that one of the punishments
that he incurs upon a people
is that he will slowly and methodically
shrink that people's space that they are
in. He will slowly and methodically take
pieces of their land or their place
away. Whether it is figuratively or or
literally
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
that one of the punishments
was that he subhanahu wa ta'ala would
shrink their place and confine them and
make the earth
close in on them.
The companions of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam
have explained this verse in the Quran
as being the death of the scholars.
Meaning that every time a scholar dies,
our
place, our earth with its vastness
becomes that much more small and
confining
until we are on top of each other.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
Stand shouldertosh shoulder. Close all
of the gaps.
Do not join the row a row until you are
sure that the row ahead of you is
completely full to capacity.
Come together. Muster together. Close
all of the gaps. Align your shoulders
and feet with the shoulders and feet of
your two neighbors on either side of
you.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Amen.
for
[Silence]
whom you
Allah
send me Allah.
Allahel
Allahel.
[Silence]
Allah.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Amen.
in
[Silence]
Allah.
Tell me
Allahbel
[Silence]
All act.
stuff.
Brothers and sisters, asalamu alaikum.
I just would to have your attention
for a couple of minutes because there
are several programs that I want to make
sure I mention to you. First,
Imam Ali's office hours are from 5 to
8:00 p.m. Wednesday through Sunday.
Again, I repeat, from 5 to 8:00 p.m.
from Wednesday through Sunday. Ask Imam
Ali's office hours and he can be you can
schedule with him other time, but these
are the hours that he will be here
inshallah at the masid to answer the
questions you have. Now I have several
other other things that I want to
mention the youth activities and all
that stuff. The basketball club is
Wednesday and Friday. Again brothers and
sisters this is going to help your youth
to get connected to the masid inshallah
and benefit physically and spiritually
inshallah. So, it's going to be the
basketball club is Wednesday and Friday
from 4 to 6:00 p.m. Soccer group A and B
which A is 7 to 9 years old, B is 10 to
12 years old and they are 130 and 2:30
respectively. Again the soccer is
from a 7 to 9 for group A and that is at
1:30 for 10 to 1 10 to 12 group B which
is at 2:30 p.m. and that is on Saturday
inshallah.
The weekend school is on Sundays
10 to 200 p.m. Again the weekend school
which all kids of the community who may
not be able to with the rap academy or
other programs they
inshallah from that the sisters halata
is also from 11 to 100 p.m. on Saturday
the same time in parallel there's a
tajvid class also that is available so
but by the way we will be inshallah
changing the slot time starting next sun
Saturday so not this Saturday so we'll
have a chance to explain on Friday
inshallah coming Friday so as the month
is turning over to October the times
will remain the same until Saturday
inshallah next week parently
on the way out.